good morning John you were recently
making fun of my new hairstyle which is
fine because we're brothers and that's
what brothers do but coming right back
at you John I got to say what is this
what why come on we've been doing this
for eight years do you have no sense of
composition got a bunch of stuff in the
wall over here nicely placed and
visually interesting without being
distracted and then wha nothing blank
space baby Alice John help free us from
the scourge of the nothing our taxes
dead and you need to name the childlike
Empress Bastian call my name and the new
viewers gone yet some friends of mine
they have a YouTube channel where they
play board games well being drunk gave
away this improv game called that's not
my name you know the song with this is
based on it they call me hell they call
me Janet
they call me Stacy they call me air hole
that song I don't know what the actual
names on the idea the game as you go
around in a circle and you sing that
song with it that's not my name that's
not my name in it and then the next
person has to do it and they have to go
up with different names to put in it's
really fun so if ever you're bored
that's just it's a fun thing to do
Kathryn and I do it all the time they
call me Brian they call mean our goal
they call me amber they call me Jeff
that's not my name I love my name's I
used to think that butterflies were
pretty much just caterpillars that had
had some modifications made to them but
it turns out the kind of elders actually
just sort of turn into this like liquid
soupy organic goop inside of the cocoon
and then reform entirely into
butterflies and that's not even the
weird part the weird part is that
caterpillars can be taught to fear
smells and then they turn into that goop
turn into butterflies and the
butterflies remain afraid of those
smells office 2015 is redlined you guys
work so hard
max caitlin this is Callie awesomesauce
we needed to go on a different tank
because is a murderer I was too long
yeah I'm gonna cut all about books wait
ha I'm gonna use the crash course studio
this is my pile of shirts
I always need one of those scishow hi
everybody
not no way we can see all of you with
that speakers too many of you there are
40 NIC cages in here you just have one
yeah I'm fine you go ahead you keep them
close by though that's creepy yeah
that's awful OOP and crash
this stupid stairs now hi Abby
giving people a tour of our offices
thank you video we need from you no no I
should be doing that though hi Blake I'm
just showing everybody the office good
job so quiet VidCon so when we say get
out booth man we don't mean you
she's shy
mother is only thinking about Vladimir
Putin and how he's probably and that
just ordered people to be killed but
actually physically killed people
himself and that I thought you know
probably US presidents have also killed
people so I looked it up and it turns
out lots of US presidents have killed
people but mostly in combat there are
only two US presidents who definitely
killed people outside of combat
situations and they are Andrew Jackson
who killed a guy in a duel but only
after that guy shot him in the chest a
bullet that would remain near his heart
for the rest of his life and Grover
Cleveland who as the sheriff of Erie
County personally carried out two
executions of murderers even though he
could have paid a deputy $10 a piece to
do it for him forever Cleveland very Ned
Stark of you call me Bobby they call me
cry yet they call me night sky they call
me fancy that's that I named John I
think my hair looks good and get a new
poster I'll see you on Tuesday Knapp
Chad recipe got open to and you
got a scoop of the goop out Alex nice
good night Oh didn't get sleep oh yeah
plie pops can you remember that you
should have started preheating the oven
the first thing than he did like the
eighth step instead you got a book these
mothers in the oven but man I've no burn
yourself and then be very quiet for
about 45 minutes while the cook or else
to be shy about cookie Thank You
butternut squash for your life and I'm
going to consume your flesh